we're at the kitchen table and we have
toothpicks we put down one toothpick and
we notice it has two ends so at each end
we put a toothpick the toothpicks are
all the same length ideally we started
with one and we added two so now we've
got three toothpicks we notice now there
are four ends so on each end we put a
toothpick and these toothpicks actually
touch so those ends are no longer free
and we keep going we do this forever so
the next generation this is the fourth
step we had for free ends we're gonna
add four more toothpicks those those two
toothpicks met at the middle so those
ends are no longer free so now their
word there are four ends so we add four
more toothpicks now we've got eight free
ends so we add eight to things and we
keep going and the question is how many
toothpicks do we have after n
generations is there a formula well this
is a very lovely question let me show
you David Applegate my former colleague
Bell Labs made an animation of this and
a number of related sequences there we
see one toothpick next we added two
toothpicks next next this is where we
got to now we're going to add eight and
now we have 12 three ends we're going to
add twelve two things and so on so let's
watch it run we see it growing when we
get to power of two we notice something
special happens we have essentially a
square that's full of toothpicks there's
no room in the middle to add any more
toothpicks there's a horizontal line of
toothpicks at the top in the bottom and
there are four free ends so by the rule
at step 17 we're gonna add four
toothpicks the new toothpicks are always
blue so we've just added four and now if
we keep going and you can see it growing
from the corners now the interesting
thing is that the growth from the
corners after 16 generations
it's the same less the growth in the
corners after 32 so let's let it run
Freddie had my Harriet so we're coming
up to a new power of two one hundred and
twenty eight generations and again it's
growing and it's growing from the corn
it's hypnotic isn't that it's wonderful
yes but you can do this on your on your
computer at home and you can see it's
growing and it's obviously a fractal
like structure the growth from the
corners is has the growth from the
corners the corners grow like earlier
corners grow and it grows and grows and
grows and the question is how many
toothpicks do we have after n
generations and I'll show you in a
minute how we analyze this but there are
others that we were not able to analyze
so when you look at the see car in the
sky it looks like that
so that's actually a toothpick it
happens to be bent and it's got three
ends the rule is the same every free end
you add a toothpick only this time
they're going to fix now we've got four
wingtips
so we go there and they're there and
let's let it run and swatch it admire it
growing this is much more difficult we
have not analyzed this here the growth
from the corners is different at each
power of two it's still every power of
two it fills up a square as much as it
can but the growth in the corners is
much less predictable we even thought to
make a double toothpick like Omar Omar
Pole yes
isn't that wonderful let me show you a
couple of others before I show you a
little bit of the mathematics of the
analysis which is actually just as
pretty as the picture but a different a
different style II toothpick and see how
that looks
run yeah yes this is very Christmasy
snowflake II and again we don't have to
stand this at all
we know how to generate it but we don't
have a formula
how many E's a toothpick star
we go back to normal toothpicks now so
here are ten generations and you notice
that after eight generations we have a
square which is almost full as full as
it can be there's no room to put a
toothpick there are no free ends in the
square there are only four free ends so
after eight generations we add four
again it's just like at the beginning
one two three four we have eight free
ends so we add eight and we get there
and so on now in if we look at a corner
and it's focus on a corner so after a
power of two what we're left with is a
square with no no holes in it it's full
up and at each of the four corners
there's half a toothpick sticking out
the first step is all we can do is add
one toothpicks there and we'd of course
add one at the other four corners now
the next generation this has two free
ends so we add two toothpicks okay now
we have three free ends so we add three
more tooth which I'm now at generation
what is it one two three we're gonna be
able we've still got three free ends we
add one two three and now we have one
two three four free ends so we had four
toothpicks and so on after I think this
is seven steps it looks like that
and if you stare at this you see that
it's really made up of three clumps the
corner sequence after whatever it was
seven more steps and this is true for
any power of two it's not just you know
there if you go out to 128 steps we
still see the same growth 256 it still
starts the same it grows more and more
because there's more room when we're out
at 256 but the beginning is the same
always when you look at it you notice
that after a power of two beyond where
we were we have three clumps and so pay
careful attention to how many there are
we find as a formula and I was using L
for the number
in one of these clumps and here we've
got three clumps two clumps which are
seventh generational clumps and one
which is eighths generation and we get a
formula and when we actually put all the
pieces together we find that we can
explain the corner toothpicks I won't
really go into the details but there's a
very nice formula which explains after
we've gone for a power of two plus I
further steps where I is one two three
four five and so on there's a formula
for the number in the corner which
depends on K the power of two and I and
it's a very nice recurrence
once we've noticed this recurrence that
the number there's there's a way of
writing down how many toothpicks are are
in the corner in terms of something we
already know that's enough we can that
we've now essentially cracked the whole
problem we know every almost everything
about it we have we can work out if you
want to know the millionth term we can
do it easily it solved a problem and we
wrote a paper about it and well Paul
David Applegate and myself so that one
we solved in the end you might say on
the scale of things that was a pretty
easy sequence to analyze now there are a
lot of others which are not so easy like
the Siegel toothpick and the e toothpick
there is another couple of easy ones
that I think are worth telling you about
particularly as they involve one of the
famous scientists from Los Alamos New
Mexico Stanislaw ulam let's imagine we
have a large piece of squared paper and
each square is a cell and we can say
that cell is either alive or dead it's
on or off its 0 or 1
maybe it's infected or it's not infected
there's a disease spreading we want to
know how fast the disease is spreading
or maybe there's some chemical reaction
which is going on it starts off with one
cell being active and that activates
other cell
we want to know how fast does this grow
it's it's it's understandable that this
would be something that physicists and
chemists and scientists and maybe
nuclear scientists and mathematicians
people are studying epidemics and so on
this is of universal interest this
question how fast does something spread
a very simple version of this is what's
called the alarm
Warburton cellular automata and it works
on cells and it's a machine that's why
it's called an automaton it proceeds on
its own and the idea is we have to
imagine we have a huge piece of graph
paper with cells square cells and each
one is surrounded by eight others but
actually we'll only look at the four
nearest neighbors of the cell and we're
going to start off where everything is
clean the pristine board nothing is on
suddenly one of the cells gets turned on
I'll write a 1 instead of a 0 all the
other cells are 0 the rule is for this
particular automata you look at a cell
near this it gets turned on if exactly
one of your neighbors is on this has one
neighbor that's on so it gets turned on
so that one turns on those four okay now
let's go on at the next generation this
cell here has two neighbors that are on
so it does not get turned on I'll put a
zero that like why is that's a zero and
that's a zero but this cell here does
get turned on because it's got only one
neighbor that's on this is the ulema
warburton cellular tourism so let's have
a look at it no they can inversions of
this of course Conway's Game of Life
cells turn on and turn off these
particular ones only turn on you either
on or off and once you're on you stay on
and there it is it starts off with one
cell on there it is it's blue because
it's a new cell ok
next it turns on its four neighbors and
next it turns on four neighbors again if
did not turn on that one because the
rule is you turn on if exactly one of
your neighbors
is on this one has two neighbors that
are on so it stays off it is not
infected if we let it run again it's
gonna grow up and again you'll notice
that every power of two it's got a full
square and it grows from the callings
and again we can analyze it in the same
way and this one is even simpler there's
a simple formula for how many cells are
on after n generations now we've done
the same thing but our graph paper isn't
squared graph paper anymore
it's hexagonal papers like the bathroom
floors where you see hexagonal tiles
this is hexagonal tiles each cell has
six neighbors now but the rule is the
same you turn on if one of you exactly
one of your neighbors is on so watch if
we let it run it goes like this again it
has the same property that after a power
of two we have a full hexagon and it
grows from the corners but now something
really annoying or beautiful has
happened the growth from the corners
were coming up to another power of two
here watch it grow from the corners if
you stare at this you can see in here
there's a pattern of black and white
cells at the next power of two we see a
different pattern it does not repeat it
is very complicated and over there I
have a very large piece of paper with my
attempt to analyze it but you want to
see it yeah of course yeah
this is my attempt and it's not finished
I haven't given up but I haven't solved
it yet this starts down here in the
corner here and then it grows and it
grows and it grows and every you if we
look here you can see this is sixteen so
this is where we were after eight each
power of two we we get a closed hexagon
I'm just showing you one sector one
sixths of the whole pizza just a slice
so after sixteen the we have that after
32 it's like that and then if life was
simple there would be a predictable
pattern but there isn't if you look at
these squares the colored squares the
red squares there are not like the red
squares that we saw earlier there are
some similarities so I haven't given up
but this is really tricky I think this
one is doable but some of the others and
there are a lot as you saw there there
are 100 or more animations that you can
look at it and some of them are very
beautiful I particularly wanted to show
you
Fred khun's replicator graduate students
here at the University of Cambridge
asked me if I could solve it and I did
it was on the margin of what what could
be solved and what couldn't but it was
the rule is it's similar to the Olin
Warburton you turn on if the number of
neighbors that's on is odd not one as it
was for that Warburton if it's two e's
you turn off but an odd number you turn
on yeah
well the pictures are beautiful look at
this here's the first 16 generations and
then when you look at 32 generations you
ask can we break it up into pieces that
look like things we've seen earlier and
the answer is yes you can but it's a
little tricky
and the reason it's called Friedkin's
replicator is if you have some shape any
shape you like say that then after a
certain number of generations you see
two copies of it it replicates itself
that's why Friedkin being a famous
computer scientist at MIT studied many
things like this mathematical things and
so I found the game of life was sort of
overshadowing much more important things
and I did not like it we agree on that
right two and three chance you've chosen
a goat so this scenario of course should
be of more interest to us it's the more
likely scenario